au royaume uni près de 58 décès serait
dû au corps à des virus à la fin du mois
de mai sept en tout cas est les derniers
chiffres publiés par le bureau des
statistiques nationales du royaume uni
louer naisse un bilan bien plus
important que celui affiché par des
autorités sanitaires qui s'élève à 40
1883 décès depuis le début de la
pandémie est le royaume uni est le
deuxième pays au monde le plus touché
par l'épidémie coronavirus en termes de
décès juste derrière les états unis et
pour en parler nous retrouvons à
christophe chanterai vice président de
l'association british community
committee of friends bonjour christophe
chanterai merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui sur rt france alors on l'a
dit hier le bureau des statistiques
nationales pour le royaume uni à l'eau
et ness a dévoilé un bilan plus lourd
que celui des autorités au moins
cinquante mille décès aurait pour cause
suspectés ou avérés les coronavirus ses
dix mille de plus que les chiffres
annoncés par les autorités sanitaires
locales
comment vous expliquer cet écart
justement je ne vais pas capable de
l'expliquer c'est vrai que c'est bizarre
qu'il y existe un tel écart entre deux
instances de statistiques
on savait que les les chiffres
communiqués au sein du service national
de la santé ne portait que sur les cas
où il ya eu un décès un certificat de
décès pourtant la mention covè 19 donc
sans doute un sou chiffrage par rapport
à la réalité mais moi je suis incapable
d'expliquer pourquoi une telle
différence existe mais c'est peut-être
un reflet de
de plusieurs changements de stratégie de
la part du gouvernement britannique
on sait qu'ils ont commencé par par
tester les cas quand donc janvier et
février quand des cas étaient plus frais
qu'un peu nombreux et il n'y avait pas
il n'y a pas eu de confinement
confinement a été débattu longuement
mais n'a commencé que deux semaines
après le confinement en italie en france
en espagne en allemagne
après donc il ya les frontières
internationales n'ont pas été fermées à
l'époque des selon une étude de
l'université de birmingham et oxford
rien d'un bourg conjointement mise
épingle les arrivées internationales de
deux personnes donc dans le pays mais là
on est à fermer les frontières
maintenant de déconfinement partiel a
été amorcée au royaume uni et on ferme
les frontières parce que maintenant
toute personne arrivant pour les
munichois se mettre en 14ème cetc
je n'arrive pas à m'expliquer si vous
voulez logique derrière ces changements
de stratégie
christopher chanterai c'était car de de
10000 morts entre les chiffres de
l'année c'est celui des autorités
locales fait c'est bien sûr inquiétant
bien sûr celle qui est en lui le nombre
de morts est forcément déplorable et le
fait de l'avoir sous-estimé vraiment ça
c'est horrible mais on maintient des
statistiques il faut de suivi de vaud ce
faire sur le nombre de nouveaux cas
c'est le nombre de nouveaux cas qui nous
dit où on est
la pandémie et si les institutions
responsables de la collecte des données
sont pas capables de le faire bien sûr
le nombre de décès est ce qu'ils ne font
bien sûr le nombre de cas nouveaux
qu'elle quel bilan faites-vous de cette
gestion de crise au royaume uni et
comment ce bilan est perçu par par les
britanniques
je pense que les politiques qui y
résident en france vont faire la
comparaison avec ce qui se passe en
france où c'est pas sans problèmes mais
on a le sentiment que ça a été mieux
gérés en france il ya un autre point les
hôpitaux le réunis à créer les hôpitaux
spécialisés un peu comme l'avait fait
les chinois ou début mai ces hôpitaux
provisoire mais spécialisés ont très peu
fonctionné on a continué à mettre dans
les hôpitaux classique
les patients du coït 19 donc ce sont des
hôpitaux classiques sont devenus des
foyers de l'infection de transmission du
virus
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas vieux mieux
valu mettre les communications du coc
u19 dans ses nouvelles installations
provisoires mais spécialisé écarter les
hôpitaux classique propres il ya
maintenant je pense que se crée un
million de de deux cas de médecine
ordinaire nom colleen 19 qui restent en
attente c'est un un autre d'une autre
statistique très inquiétante
merci beaucoup christopher chanterai
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france je rappelle que vous êtes
vice-président de l'association british
community committee of french merci
beaucoup